No one is talking honestly about Iraq
and it's very,
very hard to say what our
responsibilities are given the unholy or
maybe it's holy mess that we have
created,
um,
in,
uh,
in Iraq
we need to shout help.
We need to ask for help from the
Europeans and we need to open
negotiations with the Iranians.
We need to be talking to the Turks,
um,
but um,
and we need to be planning our own
disengagement,
but any,
any politician,
any democratic politician who claims
that we're gonna withdraw from Iraq and
the near future is just lying to the
American people because I'm.
The Kurds don't want us to withdraw.
The Sunni chiefs don't want us to
withdraw.
The Shiite government doesn't want us to
withdraw the Saudis,
the Kuwaitis,
the Jordanians,
the Egyptians,
the Israelis and the Turks don't want us
to withdraw.
All of those allies of the United States
in the Middle East are very much afraid
of anything that looks like a defeat for
the United States and a withdrawal on
the schedule.
But it hasn't been proposed by Obama and
Clinton,
I suppose,
although they've given themselves a lot
of loopholes.
But withdrawal on that schedule would be
a defeat,
in fact,
it would,
it might be a route.
And um,
and so nobody is going to do that.
Um,
and how to plan a disengagement because
we,
we have to get out how to plan a
disengagement that doesn't,
that doesn't leave everyone that we have
worked with in the Middle East.
I'm crying how to do that is enormously
difficult.
And none of the candidates are talking
honestly about those difficulties.